Hey youtubers it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Arrow Constantine video.
So amazing, and there wasn't even a villain
in the episode.
I mean, there was a villain in the flashbacks,
but the episode was really about mending things.
Like mending Sara's soul, mending the relationships
between the group members.
So careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet.
And real quick reminder, the reverse flash
ring giveaway is new again this week's all
you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
So I'll start by explaining the big stuff
first Constantine in this DC TV universe what
you what's going on in the future the deal
that they did for this episode was just for
the one episode they they don't have any contract
signed for Matt Ryan to come back on any of
the shows they were barely able to make the
schedule work to get Amarnath because he shooting
a movie and he's doing a Broadway play is
a really busy guy but he's totally willing
to come back into the character's was able
to probably try to do is bring them on legends
of tomorrow sometime in the future and he
gave all over that magical tattoo the Chinese
characters so they're just like a number of
different ways to insert him especially now
that arrow is doing magical storylines so
no more Constantine on screen for the foreseeable
future but they might reference them like
they might be my to the phone call thing for
the reference advice that they got from him
in the past but on the top five WTF so number
five Oliver's new campaign manager who you
might recognize from suburban Tory advises
him to break ties with Laurel because of what
happened with the Queen's gambit he thinks
it'll completely you don't air quotes sink
him just like the Queen's gambit this is a
really important storyline because he gets
to the core about how all of her fuels about
Laurel in the rest of her family for that
matter and his campaign strategist doesn't
know anything about what happened he still
believes the lie and everybody died in the
Queen's gambit alters the only survivor so
he doesn't know everything the Oliver's been
through with the lance family since that happened
and where things stand right now he's actually
not super close to Laurel I think they have
a certain respect for their history but the
date haven't seen super close this past season
especially since Laurel decided to become
the black canary the stuff with Sara only
makes it worse but onto number for all of
her finds out that Sara is still alive WTF
what happened to spot a the really important
thing I think they did with this Sara storyline
is not tell it completely from all of her's
perspective he's almost like a bystander they
really tell it from the a and Laurel's perspective
like Laurel is the only one that has the level
had she like look I did this because I knew
you wouldn't approve you this crazy double
standard where you keep secrets from us so
we have to start keeping secrets from you
and then tangentially we also get Thea's perspective
were she feels so remorseful that she's ready
to die achievement tell Sara when she comes
her hospital bed I want to do it I want you
to kill me how hard it must she be that she's
ready to die which I talk a little bit about
some of the inconsistency in her character
in last week's episode sometimes issued episodes
out of order so maybe that's why she seems
so bipolar but onto number three Sara versus
Thea is one of the best speedy bites all season
now Willa Holland of the people that do stunts
for Willa Holland have been doing an amazing
job this the speedy stonework is great completely
on point in her working with the screen mistakes
with all of her is just like last season when
they were on the island trained together but
Sara is still always going to be the more
powerful fighter so she just dances on Theo's
face in email they pretty much fixed during
this episode like the rebound her sold her
body Sara still gonna be a little bit crazy
but even though Thea goes down hard you can
you can still see that she's actually turning
into a really bad ass fighter so I think in
the next season or two you'll see some really
awesome speedy stuff and now that Laurel and
Oliver have galvanized their friendship I'm
hoping will see all of her train Laurel finally
because it seems like he keeps putting that
off like I'm not can train you are not going
to train you I feel like Laurel's overcome
every single one of his objections like that's
the point of this episode that Oliver finally
opens up so he has to start training her at
some point on the number two though WTF reveal
Diggle learns that his brother was actually
a crime lord in the middle east during the
war the producers said that this in no way
gives Diggle closure so this is in close the
book on his brother by any means but I think
with her trying to do with a lot of these
characters the season is blur the lines between
good and evil you have Harrison wells and
the flash who is not a villain but he's not
good either like he's not nice so just because
someone like Quentin has been really dirty
doesn't mean that they're not a good character
anymore you think Diggle's can soften up a
little bit when it comes to Quentin and if
anybody on arrow is listening right now please
write more Diggle in Quentin scenes that was
one of the most fun parts the episode the
two dudes with the lowest level of tech literacy
have to hack Damien Darhk's speed which Mr.
terrific a course he is actually wearing the
Fairplay jacket and gave a shout out for being
the bronze medal that the Catholic the Olympics
big big comic book Easter egg that text storyline
is all about surfacing the atom if you didn't
see the teaser for next week they're going
to answer a lot of questions about what's
going on with Ray Palmer and that's all flowing
out of that Felicity Mr. terrific storyline
and finally on my number one WTF moment Constantine
comes into the arrow verse and he is now old
friends with all of her he shows up in the
flashbacks first Oliver meets him helps him
recover magical artifacts to keep it out of
the hands of Berendt Ryder here but then tells
him that the island itself is a magical nexus
just full of all kinds of places that people
can get themselves into trouble the name Leanne
you literally means purgatory so of course
it's a magical nexus so they can potentially
mind the island for more magical storylines
that they wanted to the location that Constantine
made all of her taken to on the island which
is one of many magical places there but as
I mentioned he uses the grimoire to transfer
the tattoo to all of her it's those are Chinese
characters and he says this is insurance you
know how to use it when you need to so we
need to see all of her use that in the flashbacks
or we could see him use it in present-day
because I believe he still has the tattoo
so I don't know if it's a one use only kind
of thing but I'm I'm hoping that they actually
tie in with the Damien Darhk storyline in
present-day though when Constantine shows
up he makes the joke about bonding someone
sold to the body is is all I've done this
once before maybe like a year ago he just
making a joke about Constantine season one
on NBC they did something similar in an episode
of that so him was just him making fun of
Constantine being canceled let me know in
the comments what was your favorite thing
from the episode was a Constantine just just
coming on or was it then going to the spirit
world to recover Sara's soul the sword fighting
the constant he was doing those people they
were fighting those are just random spirits
it wasn't anyone in particular but like I
said don't expect to see Constantine again
anytime soon but they might reference them
or reference things that he is said in the
past certifies that he's given they're going
to have to figure out how do you see Damien
Darhk and that's going to require magical
knowledge so they had to get that from somewhere
and if anything like the next most magical
things going to be happening on the show is
Hawkman and Hawkgirl speaking of which next
week is episode six episode eight is the Vandal
Savage crossover episode with the flash switch
to get to be meeting Hawkman pretty soon that's
why Ray Palmer's coming back in a big way
next week just because they have to introduce
this legends of tomorrow cast before episode
eight so what can happen next is is him and
to do my agent to shield video they finally
revealed who lash is, so I won't post that
spoiler here I'll save that for my agents
of shield video and then I'm going to do a
Supergirl video and then there's the warcraft
trailer on Friday that should be like Friday
morning.
While you guys wait for all that stuff you
can click here for the flash by one of the
best that you are and here for my Gotham video
that I just posted thank you so much for watching,
everybody let's high five and see you guys
tonight!